learning a language is kind of like a
video game
i mean kind of not like not exactly the
same but let me explain
i'm not a big gamer i you know i've
played my fair share of super smash
brothers but
that was like when i was a teenager but
lately i'm getting back into it
we got a nintendo switch i've been
playing with my boys zelda
this cool game called cardo has to do
with maps good times
another thing i've been doing during
quarantine is
not traveling last fall when i started
realizing that kovit wasn't going away i
would not be traveling anytime soon
i decided to get my travel buzz by
learning a new language
italian the language that is spoken in
my favorite region
on earth right up here
four months ago i didn't speak a word of
italian
and today
so i've been driving back from work and
speaking
to myself in italian i am feeling
my head there's like a physical buzzing
that happens
for the past three months i've been
studying italian in the morning and
playing video games with my kids at
night
i recently started to realize how some
of the major lessons from video games
can be
applied to learning a new language and
to do so in
a much more efficient way than was
taught to us in school
by the end of this video i want to
explain this concept of
video games and language learning i want
to give you my best takeaways on
teaching yourself
a new language so back to video games my
favorite video games
are ones with maps
[Music]
big surprise he's a big map guy he loves
maps i know i'm like a walking cliche
i just like maps okay so if learning the
language
is sort of like a video game here's the
map of the video game
this is the learning language journey
you start here
knowing nothing about your new language
and your goal is to beat the final boss
this elusive idea of fluency
in other words when you start your link
and you just woke up from a 100 year nap
and you have three hearts and no weapons
and no stamina and no skills and
no powers and you don't speak the
language
where you want to be is like this
having lots of skills and tools to
navigate a conversation with precision
and skill and beat the game in other
words to become
fluent but wait wait wait okay this is
a moment this is a thing i need to
distinguish a distinction we need to
make
what is fluency what does that even mean
i'll turn the question on you gamers out
there
what does it mean to beat a video game
one person will tell you that beating a
video game means just beating the main
story line
beating the main boss ganon bowser
whatever
i can already feel some of you shaking
your heads because there are lots of you
out there that say no no no beating a
video game means beating
everything all of the challenges all of
the little
things like beating the shrines and
getting all the core oak seeds and all
the other things that have nothing to do
with the main storyline
you have to beat them all or you haven't
beaten the game
okay so here's where the connection
between language learning and the video
game concept
comes together when you're learning a
language and language school
or most formal programs the map looks
like this
[Music]
you start here knowing nothing and the
journey to beat the game to become
fluent is a long windy
path with lots of gates and trials and
gatekeepers
there are soldiers who are standing
guard making sure
that you beat them before you go on to
the next step you can't progress along
this path
until you've memorized how to conjugate
the present imperative tense
including the irregular forms so you
study them you study study study just to
make it past this first gatekeeper
you don't even really know what present
imperative means but you look at the
book you memorize it
and you do what you need to do to show
up and pass the test so that you can
move on to the next
thing that they're teaching you in the
school formal environment so then you
move on and you get to the next
gatekeeper and the trial which is you
can't move on until you've memorized the
subjunctive
conjugations and you're like what does
subjunctive mean and it's just like
i don't know but you need to go memorize
it oh and memorize this random list of
20 words that
we think are important it's the only way
to fluency
if you want to be fluent you have to get
through this gate
okay i'll memorize the subjunctive you
keep going on your journey passing the
gatekeepers
memorizing the concepts that are in the
book that the teacher is telling you
and the idea here is that if you beat
all of these gatekeepers and you
memorize all these rules you make it to
the final level
and you beat the final boss and then you
are
fluent the problem is this isn't a fun
video game
it's actually a grueling process of
memorizing
abstract ideas so people don't actually
beat the video game very often
they usually give up around here and
they say
eff it and they throw in the towel and
they feel
like language learning is just not for
them
meanwhile some of us beat the game like
i actually beat the game in college
i got a minor in french like a minor
like i
studied french through all of the levels
in college to get a minor i beat this
game
and i finally beat the final boss i got
here to the end of the map
and i had all the conjugations the
direct object pronouns the past
conditional and auxiliary verbs and
all of it and then i go to paris and i
go to order a baguette and i realize
that i
literally don't know how to order a
baguette
in paris even though i have a minor in
french there is nothing more
disappointing
than that it's sad luckily there's a
happy ending to this video
this story that i'm telling you but
right now it's just sad to think about
getting a minor in french and then
not actually being able to speak it oh
i need a little bit of a change of pace
i'm gonna crack open a bottle of wine
which begins the next segment which is
thanking today's sponsor who sent me a
giant box
full of literal wine look at this
[Applause]
whoops check this out this box arrived
on my door two days ago
inside of the box there are some really
cool things
so bright sellers who sponsored today's
videos sent me
this box they had me take a quiz before
on
things that i like the type of food and
the types of
like personality traits i have like all
this whole like
quiz and then they used the information
from that quiz to send me
this box of wine what i like about this
is because when i go
to buy wine at a store i have no
guidance like there's no guidance for me
i'm not super well versed
in all of the different variables that
make good wine i'd like to be
but it's big and complicated and for
someone to automate that
and to present it in a way that's fun
and and like sort of empowering with
information
that's actually my favorite part about
the whole thing is they will send me
these cards for each bottle of wine that
has
a little infographic on it i like
infographics that's like my thing
is like there's maps and there is
origins and there's a
story about like where this came from
there's flavor notes if you're into the
flavor notes game
for me ritualistic things like cheese
and wine
and all of it is way more enjoyable if
there's a
like story associated with it bright
sellers is giving 50
off which is half off for anyone who
clicks the link in my description for
your first six bottles so you can sign
up for this sweet thing
get six bottles for 50 off and it's a
really good deal and again the
convenience the information the
experience of this
is is really cool i'm excited i'm
excited to explore this and have some
knowledge and story associated with it
so thank you brightsellers for
sponsoring this video
let's get back to the story of learning
italian
through a video game map
[Music]
i beat the game i got here and realized
that this version of
fluency was one where i had a deep
understanding of french grammar
i even had an understanding of its
history i could read literature in
french
i could write properly i knew where all
the accents went i even had a decent
pronunciation but i couldn't speak the
damn language when i traveled to france
like wasn't that the whole point
for all you zelda people out here let's
just say i had gathered all the korok
seeds and beat all the shrines
but still hadn't beat a single divine
beast
the thing that actually mattered to me
the thing i wanted to do
what if i decided that this isn't where
i wanted to go
at all this version of fluency wasn't
important this isn't the game i want to
play
what if we decided to take a different
approach
a different path a much simpler goal and
what if that goal were as simple as
i want to be able to travel to a foreign
country and be able to speak to the
locals and have them understand me
and be understood when they speak to me
okay what like is that revolutionary
like
no mastery of grammar no perfect
pronunciation
no ability to read and write with any
elegance
no literature or cultural history of the
language
just the ability to use words to
communicate
and then to understand the response
nothing else
no core oak seeds i can already hear the
comments
but you're learning a language you have
to know the grammar or you won't be
fluent or in other words if you don't
gather all the coral exceeds you didn't
beat the game
listen if my definition isn't fluency
for you
i don't want your fluency i don't need
it i just want to be able to go on a
trip
and speak to the locals and ask for
directions and have a conversation with
a taxi driver and order food that is
all i want i'm being a little snarky
here because the language learning
community on the internet has some very
strong opinions
and expectations about what real
language learning looks like
you may see them in the comments telling
me that my italian actually isn't valid
because i don't understand the past
conditional tense not sure how to
respond to that but
i reject your objection so
a few months ago i set out to test this
out to see what this
destination looks like not this
but this i learned a lot and ended up
making an entire
course about it with my friend nathaniel
drew but i want to summarize
the major things i learned and share
them with you
[Music]
montagne
it's intense it's uncomfortable and it's
disorienting
okay before i dive in and give you
exactly the things i learned in this
process
let me do a few disclaimers that might
be helpful to some of you who actually
want to
take away some value from this video
number one is that this is my experience
it's my experience it applies to me in
my unique situation
it worked well and it may work for you
and it may not work for you
but don't see this as like a plug and
chug formula that is not what this is
this is my perspective and my experience
number two i wanted to be clear that i
spoke
literally zero italian in like october
of last year i am fluent in spanish
which is a romance language which is
like a cousin to italian
and i did study french in college as
i've mentioned 57 times so
i had some advantage but the reality is
i knew zero italian
i could say things like ciao and like
that was it
pero adeso
a
[Music]
that's what matters that's what i care
about i rejected
this and i think there's a better way
[Music]
but it doesn't mean it's easy it means
that it's just more
direct there are still trials they're
just the most efficient
trials you need and here they are
[Music]
number one not all words are created
equal
the first thing i did was to assess what
are the most
common and useful 1000 words in a
language
and solely focus on those completely
blocking out
all others this isn't a new concept
scholarly research shows that this is
very useful
and i history does too i last year was
reading a lot about american imperialism
for
obvious reasons and i stumbled upon this
wild story
after world war ii the british and
americans who had just won the war
wanted to spread the english language of
the whole world so they adopted a
stripped-down version that they called
basic they were carefully selected words
they were the most frequently used and
most useful
850 words in the language by the way
english has like over 150 000 words
and this language created by a linguist
of english was only 850 words and they
use this
to go promulgate english around the
world they're like anyone in the world
can learn english very quickly if they
just have to learn these 850 words
the inventor of the language once said
quote it takes
400 words of basic to run a battleship
and with 850 words you can run the
planet
he literally said that like this is like
an extreme version
of what i'm talking about here some
words are more important than others and
if you just memorize
those words those words that you
actually are going to use then you can
like
supercharge your language learning
process now this is where my friend
nathaniel drew comes into the story
nathaniel
is a guy who loves languages like i do
and
he also believes in this more direct
path
so he's challenged himself to learn as
much of a new language as
quickly as he possibly can all on his
own by the way much to the chagrin
of language learning internet
communities who love
to say that people are learning
languages the wrong way because it
doesn't
fit their model in doing so nathaniel
realized the same thing the british and
american governments realized in like
the
40s that if you just prioritize the most
vital words the ones that you actually
use
you can rapidly acquire a language if
you block out all other words and only
focus
on the most important nathaniel had made
a list of what he deemed to be some of
the most important words for his life
and for just everyday communication he
gave me that list and i
added to it i did a bunch of research on
the data of most frequently used words
and i put it together into a list of a
thousand words that i think
are the startup kit the most important
words you need to memorize
the ingredients the building blocks of a
language this is the first step
before you do anything else memorize the
most
important words of a language how do you
memorize all these words
i'm not gonna go into it right now i
have this box that i use
that has all my words and in the course
that we made i go into exactly how this
thing works
it's based on all the psychology that
forces these words into your long-term
memory the point is
memorize the most vital frequently used
words first
and your life will be a lot easier in
learning this language
i saw this okay like just recently like
i went from
knowing zero words in italian to within
the first
week knowing 200 words of italian you
can't speak super well with just 200
words and no grammar but
you can certainly start to express
yourself
i kept memorizing and soon i had like
500 words
and you won't believe what 500 words can
do for your ability to communicate
okay this gets to the second trial on
our video game adventure
[Music]
which is start talking early
language isn't math in math there are
laws
if you break those laws your equation
won't work
you literally get the wrong answer there
are wrong answers and right answers in
math if my four-year-old son
says 2 plus 2 equals 22 i will say
no son that's wrong 2 plus 2 equals 4.
but if my son says yesterday i
eated a apple i wouldn't say no son
yesterday you ate an apple get it right
next time
no i wouldn't say that the kids said
words i understood them and it worked
that's language it isn't math it's an
expressive part
of our human experience that is very
intuitive
and very flexible and messy like human
culture
and relationships it is not math when we
approach language
like this
we make language feel like math like if
we don't get the conjugations correct
it'll be like we're saying 2 plus 2
equals 22 and you'll be totally wrong
and no one will understand you and all
that does is make you nervous
and averse to actually speaking in real
time
but watch this i'm about to show you me
speaking italian
a month and a half six weeks after
studying it going from zero words
to a few hundred words and trying to
speak it
speaking with a native in italy over
skype
and spoiler alert for those italian
speakers my grammar
is horrible in questa quest
questo
but guess what she understood me
i was communicating in a different
language with somebody
it's not pretty it's not linguistically
correct
but it's communication what i'm
proposing is that this is the
alternative path this is the goal
not getting the mathematical equations
of grammar and syntax correct as you
memorize loads of words
the next most important step is to get
yourself speaking as soon as possible
you'll have to do this eventually if you
want to speak the language and it's
awkward and painful
and so you should start early right away
on week one
of learning the language you should get
on one of these services
and start communicating with a native
speaker
and now i'm about to say something that
actually pains me which is
after two months of this just memorizing
tons of words
and having weekly skype conversations
with a native italian
i was speaking better italian more
fluently
than i was french i eclipsed my french
capabilities
from a verbal standpoint not from a
grammar standpoint but from a verbal
expressive standpoint after two months
compared to
four years of work i'm not saying it was
fluent after two months i'm just saying
that my experience after two months was
stronger than my four years of
college french that's like actually sad
for me in some ways because
there's so much time of me learning
french and it just
oh there's a better way in the course
that i mentioned i go into a deep dive
on all the types of activities that i do
in one of these sessions with a native
speaker that
helps make it useful but i'm not gonna
go into that right now okay gate number
three
you gotta make this fun another major
thing missing from
this model is fun
positive association is how it's called
in behavioral psychology
the idea that your brain wants to
do something if last time they did it it
was sort of fun language learning is
hard it requires many months and years
how do you keep it up you make it
interesting and fun grammar drills
and memorization are not fun so you have
to find ways
to make it a positive experience
for me that is reading an italian
cookbook that has italian language that
i can translate and
think about italian cuisine which is
something i love i also started
listening to harry potter in italian
which i didn't understand a single word
at first but then i got the kindle
version and i sort of followed along
uh digitally and translated some words
while i was listening
and now i can like understand probably
80 to 90
of harry potter because i love harry
potter don't love jk rowling though
love harry potter okay so make it fun
the last
and final gate in this more direct
journey to
being able to speak a language is the
one that people who have learned other
languages have been waiting for me to
say
and they're angrily being like dude you
gotta mention this and i'm gonna say it
which is yes
eventually you have to learn the rules
you have to learn grammar you have to
learn pronunciation
and you have to refine it through drills
and through a lot of practice
intentionally i'm putting this last
because i think you should too
the previous concepts are way more
important get your first
500 or a thousand words memorized in
your long-term memory
start speaking every week with a native
speaker make the journey fun
and then start to think about grammar
and start to think about
all of the rules and the irregulars and
the syntax and the direct object
pronouns and the past participles
you can do that after maybe two three
months of like being in the trenches
the best part about this is that by that
time you'll be in a place where you can
communicate
basic ideas so that when you do look at
the grammar
it actually fits into the context that
you've intuitively developed
of expression it won't just be like in a
vacuum of memorizing arbitrary rules
it'll actually apply to something and
that makes it way more
interesting to actually memorize i
didn't start really going into grammar
until just recently three months into
the process of learning italian
and it makes a lot more sense okay so
that is what i've learned about
learning another language it's like a
video game you don't need to gather all
the korok seeds to beat the game
you don't some people think you do i'm
not gonna listen to those people
for me to beat the game you just need to
be able to talk
and be understood this is my experience
this is my
version of it and again in the course i
go deeper into exactly how this goes
down
the course that me nathaniel did is like
three and a half hours of like
nitty-gritty techniques and all this
stuff but the message
is what i've told you here which is that
there's a better way to learn
languages than the way we learned it in
school
i will be studying italian for years but
the beautiful thing is
next time i go to italy which who knows
when that's going to be but
at some point i'll go to italy i'll show
up to a cafe and i'll be able to speak
i'll be able to talk and be understood
and that's what matters to me so i hope
that's what matters to you too
thanks for watching